[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياضه نبداها بالعناوين
رئيس وزراء بريطانيا يقولون رساله طائرات
المقاتله اوكرانيا امر غير عمليه في هذه
اللحظه
النتيجه
اعلى معدل نمو خلال السنوات السابقه
الصفقات العقاريه في السعوديه تسجل
انخفاضا بنحو 23 في المئه خلال العام
في الرابعه ايضا
الهيئه الملكيه للعلا تكشف عن زياره اكثر
من
185,000 سائح العمل الماضي
والمركز السعودي للحياه الفطريه يقول انه
انتهى من حصريخ 5
لتجمع قروض البابونج
قال رئيس الوزراء البريطانيه كنا ارسال
الطائرات المقاتله الاوكرانيا امر غير
عمليه في هذه اللحظه
وعزت هناك ذلك الامر الى ان الطائرات
المقاتله البريطانيه متطوره للغايه
ويستغرق الامر شهورا للتدريب على تشغيلها
وكدار البريطانيين ان بلاده ستواصل مناقشه
ذلك الامر مع حلفائها للتوصل للنهج الصحيح
في الدعم العسكريه
لقد اعلنا وزير الدفاع النرويجي اريل
ترامب بان بلاده ستنقل دبابات البارد
اثنين المانيه الصنع لوكرانيا نهايه تمارس
القادم في من لم يحدد الوزير النرويجي
عددها الا ان بلاده تملك 36 دبابه من طراز
البارد 2 وكانت المانيا اعلنت انها ستسمح
للدول الاخرى التي تملك هذه الدبابات
بنقلها الى اوكرانيا ايضا
وقد ظهرت صور متداوله نقل مركبات مشاهد
قتاليه امريكيه من طراز برادلي الى
اوكرانيا في اطار حزمه المساعدات العسكريه
الكبرى التي اعلنت عنها الولايات المتحده
بقيمه ثلاثه مليارات دولار وكان المتحدث
باسم البنت رايدر قال في وقت سابق ان
مركبات برادلي ليست مدرعه بل قاتله مدرعات
وقد اعتبر رئيس جهاز الاستخبارات الخارجيه
الروسيه سيرجينال شيكين ان الراي العام في
اوروبا ليس متجانسا كما تريده واشنطن وقال
ان وجود المتطوعين الفرنسيين في صفوف
المدافعين عن دوم بس وكذلك اجتماع الذكرى
الثمانين للنصر في معركه ستالينغراد
وتاكيد واضح على ذلك وشدد على انه في ظل
الظروف الحاليه اصبح الحوار الصادق
والموضوعي حول الماضي والمصمم لتوحيد
القوه البناء اداء اهميه
اليابان حيث تقال الامين العام لحلف شمال
الاطلسي يونبرغ من قاعده ايرون الجويه ان
انتصار بوتين في حرب اوكرانيا سيرسل رساله
خطيره بانه يمكن تحقيق الهدف باستخدام
القوه العسكريه
لكنها سترسل ايضا رساله خطيره
في جميع انحاء العالم لان الرساله بعد ذلك
ستكون عندما يستخدمون القوه العسكريه
يمكنهم تحترق اهدافهم
افاده مراسل العربيه باعلان حاله التاهب
الجوي في اوكرانيا بعد دويه انذار وقبل
ذلك مراسل العربيه
مع قتال الشوارع في مناطق مختلفه من
المحور الشمالي
رئيس الاداره العسكريه لمقاطعه اخر كيف
تالي جانتي اعلن ان القوات الروسيه تتسيطر
على 25 بلده في المقاطعه واشار الى صعوبه
الوضع في خاركب مؤكدا ان المقاطعه تتعرض
للقصف باستمرار الامر الذي يجبر لاداره
المدنيه والعسكريه المحليه في المقاطعه
على اجلاء السكان وكانت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه اعلنت في وقت سابقا اعاده تجميع
القوات المتميزه في منطقه بلاك ليا
وايزيوم في مقاطعه خاركب لتعزيز الجهود في
وقد نشات القوات الاوكرانيه وقواعد عسكريه
جديده قريبه من نقاط تمركز القوات الروسيه
التي سيطرت عليها مؤخرا في منطقه كامناسكي
وعلى الاتجاه الرئيسي من بلده اوريغفا
لمدينه زاكروشي تعزيز القوات الاوكرانيه
القواعد باليات ومدافع ومنصات الصواريخ
لضرب مناطق تابعه لروسيا في مناطق او في
مقاطعه زابرجه
المتابعين ضم الينا من دانيات مراسل
العربيه رائد الاخضر اهلا بك رائد ما
الجديد حتى الان في تطورات المعارك على
الميدان في محاور الصراع
خالد يعني لابد من الاشاره اولا الى ان
هناك عوده روسيه في الفتره الاخيره اذا
تحدثنا عن الشهر الاخير باكمله هناك تقدم
روسي واضح على جميع المحاور ان كانت
الشماليه او الجنوبيه ان كان في زاباروجه
وخرسون او حتى هنا في دانيت يعني ايضا هذا
يؤكد ان القصف الاوكراني على مدينه دانيت
خلال الفتره الاخيره انخفض
انخفضت وتيته لدرجه كبيره حتى ان الاعداد
يعني اعداد القدائق والصواريخ التي كانت
تسقط على المدنيين كانت بالمئات الان
نتحدث عن عشرات القذائف والصواريخ
الاوكرانيه التي تسقط
بمناطق متفرقه لكنها همم لا تؤدي الى
اصابات ولا الى ضحايا اوتله وهذا يشير الى
نقص الذخيره ايضا عند جانب الاوكراني ما
يدل ان الجيش الروسي يدفع بالفعل ويسيطر
على مزيد من البلدات كما تعلن القوات
الروسيه والسلطات المحليه هنا هذا من جانب
الجانب الاخر بالفعل يعني التطورات على
الارض والمعارك ما زالت قوات فاجنر تحاول
التقدم في البلدات شمال مدينه طباخ من حيث
اعلنت اليوم الدفاع الروسيه عن سيطره همم
قوات باغنر على بلده بلاجاباتنا وهذه
البلده التي دارت جد حول سيطره الجيش
الروسي عليها من عدمه وسط انكاركي اليوم
اعلان الدفاع الروسيه يشير الى ان السيطره
تمت بالكامل لان الجانب الروسي دائما ما
يتريق المقصود الدفاع الروسيه ما تتريق
بالاعلان عن السيطره على اي بلده او اي
مدينه ويكون يعني المقاتله قد اعلنوا عن
السيطره عليها قبل يومين او ثلاثه على
الاقل هذا من جانب وجانب الاخر المنطقه
التي تجمع مقاطعه
بالفعل هي ملتهبه خالد هذه هي المنطقه
تشهد همم يعني هجوم لجانب الاوكراني ورده
فعل من الجانب الروسي على عده محاور
وبلدات قصف همم لا يتوقف من جانب الجيش
الروسي الذي يقصف كل تقدمات الجيش
الاوكراني لكن الجيش الاوكراني من الواضح
انه مصمم منذ اكثر من شهر شهرين تقريبا او
اكثر منذ سحاب القوات الروسيه وعودتها الى
منطقه كريمنا في لوغانسك والجيش الاوكراني
يحاول الوصول الى الطريق السريع والسيطره
عليه طريق صفاته اذا تذكر خالد ما زالت
القوات الاوكرانيه تحاول السيطره على
بلدات حول اصواتها يعني توقف هذه الهجمات
الدفاعات الروسيه وحسب التصريح الرسمي
لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه بانها تحيد مئات
الجنود وتدمر عشرات الاليات في ذلك المحور
الصراع الكبير على ذلك المحور لان المنطقه
بالفعل الاستراتيجيه وهي تجمع همم
المقاطعات الثلاث واذا سيطر احد الطرفين
على هذا المثلث الخطير جدا يمكن ان تتقدم
القوات للعوده الى مناطق قد سيطر عليها
الطرف الاخر شكرا جزيلا لك من دنيتك مراسل
العربيه رائد الاخضر
شهيده السودان اليوم تمشينا ولا مره خالي
مشروعي توفير المياه في ولايات السودان
لحفر 500
المشروع السعوديه
الى ثلاثه ملايين مستفيد لتعزيز التنميه
الاقتصاديه في المناطق الريفيه السودانيه
اظهرت بيانات الهيئه العامه للاحصاء في
السعوديه نمو الناتج المحليه الاجماليه
بخمسه فاصل اربعه من العشره في الماء على
اساس الثانوي في الربع الرابع من العام
الماضي
خلال العام الماضي وذلك وفق تقديرات
الهيئه العامه للاحصاء التقرير كشف
مشاهدينا كذلك النمو الرابع
بخمسه واربعه عشر في المئه وذلك مقارنه
بالربع الرابع من عام
2020 هذا الارتفاع جاء مدفوعه بنمو
الانشطه غير النفطيه بس 26% اضافه الى نمو
الانشطه نفطيه لسته
او حققت انشطه الخدمات الحكوميه بواحد
و18% وفي نظره تفصيليه للاعوام الثمانيه
الماضيه لنمو الناتج المحليه السعوديه نجد
بان العام الماضي حقق نموا كبيرا حيث سجل
كما ذكرنا ثمانيه وسبعه عشر في المئه في
حين سجل في عام 2018 نموا باثنين وثمانيه
عشر في المئه قبل ان يسجل انخفاضا بالسالب
وصل الى
34% في عام 2020 وبعد كده بسبب تداعيات
جاء احد كارونه اما الانشطه نفطيه فقط
سجلت عفوا خلال العامين الماضيين 20 22 21
حيث سجلت نمو بسبعه وعشرين في المئه وخمسه
عشر
و14% على التوالي الانشطه غير النقديه
مشاهدينا والتي تسعى السعوديه لتعزيزها من
خلال برنامج رؤيه 20 30 فقد سجلت في عام
2019% في ما سجلت في العام الماضي 20 واحد
انه 20 او في عام 20 21 نموه بس 27% في ما
سجل في العام الماضي خمسه و14%
ينضم الينا في استديوهاتنا من رياض استاد
الماليه والاستثمار في كليه الاقتصاد
بجامعه الامام دكتور محمد دكتور محمد حياك
الله يسلمك دكتور خليني ابدا معك عن قراءه
في هذه الارقام
اولا كيف تقيم هذا التسارع في النمو
للناتج المحلي وما العوامل التي دفعت
بالوصول لهذا الرقم
ناتج محلي جدا ممتاز همم خصوصا انه احنا
بنعرف انه العالم بيمر في ازمه اقتصاديه
فانت اليوم لما بتكون تعتبر الرقم الاعلى
نموا على مستوى مجموعه العشرين ايضا ما
ننسى انه هذا الرقم مدفوع كان همم حوالي
15 اكثر من 15% في الانشطه النفطيه وعندنا
سته فاصله 20 همم يعني همم في الانشطه غير
النفطيه المتتبع الحقيقه لسنه 22 راح يجد
انه فعلا احنا حققنا اهداف انا يمكن
بنهايه همم الوصفه الاول انه كانت
الارتفاع عالي جدا في ما يخص الانشطه
النفطيه بحوالي 22.9% همم ايضا كان في
ارتفاع من ثلاثه فاصله 9% في الانشطه غير
النفطيه الى 5.9% في النصف في النصف الاول
وبالتالي من هنا بدانا نتوقع انه نهايه 22
هتكون اعلى من ثمانيه ونصف همم بالمئه نمو
ناتج محلي الجميل في الارتفاع الحقيقه هو
زي ما ذكرنا ما عملت عليه السعوديه خلال
الفتره الماضيه وهي الانشطه غير النفطيها
بنركز كثير يعني نشتغل غير النفطيه في
الكوارتر الاول احنا كنا بنتكلم على ثلاثه
فاصله تسعه بالمئه ارتفعت ل 5.9% في
الكوارتر الثاني في في الربع الثالث احنا
وصلنا الى سته فاصله واحد بالمئه واليوم
احنا بنتكلم على 6.2% في الربع الرابع
فمعناته في تدرج وارتفاع في معدلات النمو
انشطه غير النفطيه وبالتالي اصبح النمو
العام في عام 22 ب 5.4% وهذا ما في شك انه
جد رائع في ظل يعني وحياه الهيكليه
الاقتصادي اللي قاعده تشتغل عليها
السعوديه ولله زالت تعمل عليها فنعرف انه
اليوم في حرص كبير في مساله ان يكون في
عندي موازنه صحيح بين كيف يكون عندي
استدامه ماليه وفي نفس الوقت يكون عندي
انجاز لكل المبادرات اللي عملت عليها
الحكومه في ااه يعني في رؤيه 2030 وانجاز
لتحقيق الاهداف في عام 22 نحن اطلقنا خمسه
استراتيجيات في قطاعات مختلفه لاستراتيجيه
السياحه الرقميه اطلقنا استراتيجيه النقل
والخدمات اللوجستيه اطلقنا استراتيجيه
الرياضيات
كلها كانت عوامل دفع لما يخص الناتج
المحلي في الانشطه غير النفطيه واللي
انعكست اثارها في هذا النمو الكبير اللي
احنا قاعدين نشاهده اليوم
طيب اذا قرانا هذه الارقام وهذا النمو
بهذا يعني باكثر من خمسه زي ما ذكرت خلال
سنه تقريبا
اليوم كيف نتوقع او كيف ننظر الى التحديات
الى اي مدى يمكن ان يشهد نمو في هذا
القطاع لان في اهتمام واضح بالقطع غير
النفطي وفي ارقام جلسه تسجل بشكل متسارع
ايضا لها تاثير كبير ايضا فمثلا
للتحديات خاصه في في القطاع غير النفطي
تحديدا اللي يشهد هذا النمو
لازال هناك تحديات اقتصاديه كبيره في
العالم احنا لازم لا زال العالم يعاني من
اثار جائحه كورونا لا زال العالم يعاني من
مشكله التضخم العالميه واللي استطاعت بكل
امانه همم المملكه ان هي تحاصر هذا التضخم
وتحتويه في معدلات يعني همم يعني ما يقارب
الثلاثه او حاجه امر يعني يعتبر لكن همم
اعتقد انه الرؤيه السعوديه واهداف
الاستراتيجيه اللي بتعمل عليها قادره على
انه يتجاوز اي تحديات مستقبليه صحيح انه
التفاؤل ما هو كبير في العام 23 همم لانه
فعلا لا زال هناك حاله عدم اليقين في
ضبابيه في مساله اليوم احنا بننتظر
الاجتماع القادم للفيدرالي فيما يخص
ارتفاع وهل يعني كم نقطه حيكون هناك وهذا
ما بشكل انه باثر بشكل مباشر على مستويات
التضخم بعكس لنا او مؤشرات مهمه على اسواق
المال همم اضف الى ذلك انه ال ال في ما
يخص الاقتصاد المحل يعني اعتقد كل الارقام
بتشير ان احنا امامنا ان شاء الله ارقام
ايجابيه خصوصا انه زي ما ذكرت القطاع غير
النقطه في دعم كبير من الحكومه لهذا في
القطاع القطاع الخاص همم مشاركه القطاع
الخاص تجاوزت ال 45% واحنا المستهدف عندنا
في الرؤيه حوالي 65% في الناتج المحلي اذا
همم ان شاء الله احنا مستمرين ممكن انت
تقول انه استطاعت الاستراتيجيه او الرؤيه
من خلال الاستراتيجيه المرسومه انها
تتعامل مع كل التحديات يعني كانها هي تطرح
سيناريوهات معينه همم او بتتوقعها
وبالتالي صحيح تبني عليها استراتيجتها
وطريقتها في التعامل مع فبالتالي اليوم
يعني التحديات ممكن تتضاعف خلال فتره
الجايه انت جالس نشوف تحديات التغيرات
الجيو سياسيه على مستوى العالم وكيف تحولت
من ازمه الى ايجابيه ايضا من خلال
الاقتصاد السعودي فبالتالي كيف يمكن النظر
الى هذه التحديات خلال فتره
القادمه وطريقه التعامل يعني الحمد لله
احنا بنعمل بصراحه بشكل جدا مميز في مساله
همم كيف نصيطر على اي تحديات مستقبليه همم
شاهدنا هذا في تعاملنا مع جائحه كورونا
وايضا تعاملنا مع التضخم وبالتالي ايضا
المشاكل الجنسيه يعني عكست حتى على
مستويات يعني كان في عندنا مشاكل في
المستوى الطاقه السعوديه كانت رائده وبك
بلس وبالتالي استطعت ان تتعامل مع اسواق
النفط بشكل جدا رائعه ايضا ثم يخص ازمه
الغذاء اليوم احنا قاعدين نشاهد ايضا
مساله الشركات اللي بتعملها عليها
السعوديه لم تعد يعني تعتمد على جهه واحده
تقول امريكا او الغرب لا حتى في الشرق
نفتح يعني المختلفه الصين وغيرها الهند
ليه لانه اليوم اصبحت الحقيقه كان
الاقتصاد يعتمد على مقدار الاسواق الجديده
اللي انت بتعمل من خلالها وايضا ال- ال-
الاستثمارات الاجنبيه التي تستطيع ان
تجذبها الى اقتصادك المحلي الاقتصاد
السعودي يتمتع بكفاءه عاليه يتمتع بهيكله
همم جدا رائعه وايضا جاذب للاستثمارات
الاجنبيه وهذا في غايه الاهميه عندنا
اليوم شفنا التشريعات والانظمه والقوانين
اللي تغيرت بشكل جذري وكانت يعني عامل
مساعد ان تكون السعوديه وجهها لكل ال- ال-
يعني الاستثمارات من شتى انحاء العالم همم
عدد كبير من الشركات اليوم بتبحث على وجود
مقرها الاقليميه في السعوديه هذا ما في شك
سيد سيكون دائم كبير في مساله القطاع
الخاص ومواجهه اي تحديات محليه اضيف الى
ذلك الاستقطابه لمجموعه من الخبرات
المختلفه ايضا همم اليوم هناك نظره ايضا
ليكون عندنا اي من سوق حره مع ثانيه اكبر
اقتصاد في العالم هو الاقتصاد الصيني ما
في شك انه هذه كلها عوامل تعطي ايجا لو
انا برا ايجابيه للاقتصاد السعودي اشكرك
شكرا جزيل دكتور محمد ممكن استاذ الماليه
والاستثمار في كليه الاقتصاد في جامعه
الامام شكرا دكتور العفو الله يسلمك شكرا
رابع مستمره فيها بعد قليل الارصاد
السعوديه تحذر من تقلبات جويه على معظم
المناطق حتى الجمعه المقبل
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنا المركز السعودي
لتنميه الحياه الفطريه عن حصري اكثر من
500 موقع تجمع لكره البابونج
ارشاديه لمواقعه تلك القرن المركز السعودي
للتنميه الحياه الفطريه نفذ ايضا 5 حملات
توعويه ضمن برنامج تقييم اضرار تزايد قروض
البابونج ووضع الحلول المعالجه
من الرياض مدير او ينضم الينا مدير عام
المحافظه على البيئه البريه في المركز
الوطني للتنميه الحياه الفطريه احمد
الدكتور احمد حياك الله معي في نشره
الرابعه تقولون بان هذا البرنامج
تقييم لاضرار لتزايد قروض البابونج وايجاد
حلول يسير وفقا الخطه الموضوع وبدعم حكومي
وشراكه من جميع الجهات ما هي النتائج اللي
وصلت
المساحات في كامل المناطق المتضرره في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وهي بالمناسبه 6
مناطق تمتد من اقصى الجنوب غرب المملكه
الى منطقه المدينه المنوره تم رصد اكثر من
500 بؤره لمشاكل برود البابونج المستانس
وتداخله مع المناطق السكنيه والمناطق
الزراعيه وتم تثبيت اكثر من 300 لوحه
دعويه
لتوعيه المقيمين والسواح اللي عدم اطعامها
لان الاطعام هو احد العناصر الاساسيه
لجذبها من المناطق البريه وتحويل سلوكها
وايضا همم عامل مؤثر حتى في فسيولوجيه
التكاثر وزياده الاعداد كذلك تمت
الاستجابه ضمن هذا المرحله الاولى من
البرنامج همم الى اكثر من 2000 بلاغ وتمت
همم كما اسلفت همم اقامه خمسه ااه حملات
توعويه بالاضافه للحمل التوعويه مع
الشركاء في المناطق المصريه
واعداد القروض ايضا تزيد وتتضاعف
المرحله الثانيه المرحله الثانيه يا استاذ
خالد اللي تبدا من همم 20 23 هذا العام ان
شاء الله
ستنطلق اعمال المعالجات الجذريه للمشكله
لان المرحله الاولى كانت تتضمن همم تطبيق
التجريبي لافضل الحلول وافضل الممارسات
للمعالجه همم على المستوى الدولي وهذا تم
همم
[موسيقى]
في همم عديد من المناطق همم اليوم نحن همم
بانتظار ان شاء الله انطلاق همم في مطلع
20 23 خلال الاسابيع القادمه بحول الله
اطلاق المرحله الثانيه من برنامج وهي
المرحله المعنيه بالحلول الجذريه ولكن
اريد ان انوه ان الحلول الجذريه تحتاج الى
تعاون من السكر همم خلينا اوقف معك على
قصه التعاون وقصه هذه الحلول الكلام هذا
الدكتور احمد احنا نسمع وصلنا عقود يعني
انا اكثر من همم 40 سنه وانا عارف المشكله
هذه خلال عملي خلال فترات كذلك حافظ مثل
هذه التصريحات خلال الفتره اللي راحت هي
كانت لك تصريحات دكتور احمد حول هذه القصه
يعني ونفس الكلام اللي صار حتى الان وحزمه
من الحلول لمواجهه مشكلات التجمعات قروض
البابونج في السعوديه
واستراتيجيات وغيرها من الامور تكرر الامر
في 2014 وعقدتم ورش عمل منها في جامعه
الملك خالد وتكلمت عن حلول بعيده المدى
وقصيره المدى وغيرها من الامور اخرها كان
في 2019 كمان كان لكم تصريحات على لسانكم
وعلى لسان كذلك نائب رئيس الهيئه الدكتور
هاني محمد الطوالي عن نفس الموضوع احنا
ليش عندنا هذه المشكله ما تنحل ليش نحتاج
كل هذه السنين لعقد الورش
لقاءات في الجامعه وخبراء عالميه وخلال
هذه السنوات كلها بدون ان نرى نتيجه على
ارضها واسمح لي هنا اقول لك وجهه نظر
البعض انه هذا ما تقوم به هو مجرد رد فعل
يعني بمعنى تحصل حادث
لمداهمه قرود لمش في اي منطقه تطلع
فيديوهات تطلع لكم تصاريح لكن على ارض
الواقع ليس هناك اي حلول لهذه المشكله رغم
كثره اللجانات اللجان والاجتماعات وغيرها
طيب
ما عمل بالسابق من دراسات ومن ورش عمل
وغيرها في هذه المشكله لم يكن هناك اي رصد
لاي مبالغ للمعالجات نحن نتحدث عن مرحله
بدون اي حلول واقعيه او عمليه مجرد بس كده
كنت لم يكن هناك مع الاسف رصد لاي
ميزانيه لمعالجه المشكله اليوم الوضع
اختلف هناك ميزانيات رصدت
لتقييم الوضع على همم على الارض الواقع من
هذا من زمان دكتور احمد انتم هذه
المعلومات اليوم توصلت لها من البرنامج
الاخير انتم عارفينها صار لكم سنوات
بالتالي ليش انتم كمان ترجعوا تعملوا
دراسات وابحاث وخبراء على اساس توصلوا نفس
النتيجه اللي وصلتوا لها قبل 10 او 15 او
20 سنه ليش ما تبدا مرحله المعالجه بسرعه
ما دام الفلوس موجوده الان
نعم السبب استر خالد هو انه لابد في اي
مشكله من معرفه خط الاساس ما لم يكن خط
الاساس واضحا لا يمكن ان تقيم مدى عملك
التقييمات السابقه همم يمكن كما تفضلت هذه
المشكله عمرها اكثر من اربع عقود انا
شخصيا عملت في هذه المشكله منذ عام
1988 منذ بدء عملي همم في همم
قطاع الحياه الفطريه همم قيمات والاعمال
السابقه القديمه تغيرت كثيرا
ااا في الوقت الحالي مع الاسف ال ال
المشكله اتفاقمت وتصاعدت في المناطق
الزراعيه والمناطق السكنيه واهلنا في
الجنوب همم
في المناطق المتضرره يعانون كثيرا والالم
الذي يشعرون به نحن ايضا نشعر به ولكن همم
اليوم نحن في مرحله مختلفه تماما من اجل
الطلاق الحلول همم الحزمه الحلول التي
اوصت بها الدراسات
والله هناك حزمه من الحضور طبعا
الحلول يجب ان نعرف الاسباب التي ادت الى
المشكله الاسباب التي الاسباب التي ادت
المشكله معروفه اليوم الحلول حزمه
الحلول المتضخمه فيها الاعداد ولكن يشتمل
ذلك على همم ايضا عمليات التعقيم ويشتمل
ذلك ايضا على عمليات الابعاد ويشتمل ذلك
ايضا على برامج التوعيه البيئيه حتى لا
تعود المشكله الى سكرتي اقصد ابداوا في
القضاء عليها يعني بالقتل الرحيم
بالطرق المعالجه اللي ذكرتها انت قبل 10
سنوات
فقط اريد ان اوضح ان ليس هناك حلا واحدا
لهذه المشكله
يعني همم مجرد فكره القضاء عليها هذا ليس
حل اذا كانت الاسباب المؤديه الى المشكله
لا زالت قائمه
ممكن تقول المواطن لانه هذا مو مبرر انه
اذا كان المواطن هو سبب في زيادتها انه
خليها بالشكل
ليس ليس فقط المواطن يطول العمر الاسباب
المشكله هو تقديم الاغذيه بشكل مباشر وشكل
غير مباشر جزء يقع على عاتق ال ال المواطن
وعلى عاتق غير المواطن
حتى لو كان هذا سبب صحيح وهو صحيح وهو
صحيح مو مبرر انه تتفاقم المشكله الى هذا
الحد ونجلس حاطين على خدنا ونقول والله
المواطنين
النفايات
الغذائيه اجلكم الله همم سواء كانت على
الطرق العامه كثير من الناس
اتكلم عن تاريخ معين فتره زمنيه محدده
نقول انه هذه المشكله خلاص
الى حد معين او انها انتهت ولا لا زال
هناك عدم تعاون بعض الجهات او غيرها من
الاسباب التي تمنع عن معالجه هذه
اللازمهم على التواصل مركز الوطني
المعنيه في معالجه المشكله انطلاق الحلول
الجذريه سيبدا ان شاء الله هذا العام 20
23 ولكن كما اسلفت اخفض الاعداد هذا ليس
حل اا النهائي افضل الاعداد مع استمرار
تقديم الاطعمه لها بشكل مباشر وشكل غير
مباشر وترك حاويه النفايات تكرر اكرمكم
الله
والنفايات الغذائيه بالذات على جوانب
الطرق يعني جذب المزيد من المجموعات
البريه وتحويل سلوكها الى سلوك مستانس
شكرا تحتاج الى التعاون وتكافل بين
المواطن وبين الجهات المعنيه داخل المناطق
المتضرره وبين المركز الوطني لتنميه
الحياه
تواجدك معنا على ما قدمته ايضا واحنا
عارفين انه عندك رحله على الانترنت
شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]
السعوديه دعت مديريه الدفاع المدني الى
اخذ الحيطه والحذر من التقلبات الجويه على
معظم المناطق ابتداء من اليوم وحتى الجمعه
المقبله وبدوره كشافه مركز الارصاد عن
توقعاته بغطول امطار تصل الى المستوى
الغزير في مدن عده منها المدينه واجزاء من
المنطقه الشرقيه من الرياض ومكه في ضمن
عدد المناطق السعوديه التي ستشهد امطارا
متوسطه بدا من اليوم
من المركز الوطني للارصاد مراسل العربيه
سلطان السلامي سلطان مرحبا اذا كان عندك
من تفاصيل ومعلومات اضافيه حول الحال
الجويه التي يرصدها المركز
اهلا بكافه المشاهدين قناه العربيه ينتظر
اهالي منطقه تبوك لهطول او موعد هطول ثلوج
على مرتفعات منطقه تبوك وتحديدا على جبل
اللوز في نيوم وكذلك على جان وكذلك
مرتفعات الظهر من المتوقع ان تبدا الحاله
بهطول الثلوج في مساء يوم الاربعاء وكذلك
فجر يوم الخميس مع انخفاض درجات الحراره
اللي تصل الى صفر درجه مئويه تفاصيل حول
الحاله الثلجيه والحاله المطريه في
السعوديه ينضم الى الان المتحدث الرسمي
باسم المركز الوطني للارصاد الاستاذ حسين
القحطاني اهلا وسهلا بك على شاشه العربيه
ماذا عن الحاله الثلجيه متى سوف تبدا
بالوقت المعين وكذلك مدى استمرارها وايضا
انخفاض درجه الحراره وكذلك مناطق المجاوره
لمنطقه تبوك اه نعم بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم نحن ندخل الربع الثاني من فصل
الشتاء تتوالى الموجات المطريه على مناطق
المملكه بشكل عام الربع الاول كان مرحله
مطيره على معظم مناطق المملكه نبدا الربع
الثاني من فصل الشتاء ايضا بحاله مطريه
جديده تشمل الاجزاء الاكبر من مناطق
المملكه ايضا بها عناصر جويه مختلفه من
تساقط الثلوج والبرد والرياح النشطه
وتذبذب نسبي في درجات الحراره وانخفاض في
معدلاتها المناطق الشماليه نحن نتوقع تلك
كما ذكرت ان فرصه تساقط الثلوج على
مرتفعات منطقه تبوك تبدا بمشيئه الله يوم
الاربعاء والخميس هناك ايضا فرص مستقبليه
لتساقط الثلوج انخفاض درجات الحراره
الحقيقه حتى الان فصل الشتاء لم يتدنى الى
ما دون الصفر على معظم مناطق المملكه
ومنها المناطق الشماليه التي عاده ما
تستقبل اولى موجات لا انخفاض درجات
الحراره على مناطق المملكه حتى الان نتوقع
تسجيل درجات الصفر المئوي لكننا لم ننزل
دون ذلك حتى اتوقع بمشيئه الله استمرار
درجات الحراره في لقفاظ على مناطق المملكه
خلال الربع الثاني من فصل الشتاء حتى
ينتهي معنا فصل الشتاء في 21 مارس لكن
التقارير المناخيه التي صدرت من المركز
الوطني للارصاد تشير ان شتاء هذا العام
دافع نسبيا يعني الكثير يسال منطقه مكه
المكرمه وكذلك المدن المحافظات على ساحل
البحر الاحمر باتجاه الجنوب هل سوف تشهد
انخفاض درجه الحراره العوده التدريجيه
لدرجه الحراره المعتده عليها المنطقه نعم
حقيقه ليس هناك يعني عوده تدريجيه نحن في
فصل الشتاء والدرجات الحراره في معدلاتها
في هذا الفصل نحن عندما تدخل علينا موجات
بارده تساهم بانخفاض درجات الحراره ادنى
من المعدل حتى الان كما ذكرت ان لم نسجل
درجات حراره دون الصفر هناك نسبي على
مناطق المملكه وكل ما اتجهنا الى المناطق
الساحليه خاصه الغربيه من المملكه لكن
نتوقع استمرار درجات الحراره في انخفاضها
في هذا المعدل حتى نهايه الربع الثاني على
عجاله مدعم منطقه مكه وجده تحديدا اليوم
حقيقه من ضمن الحاله الجويه المؤثره على
مناطق المملكه لكن لا يوجد مؤشرات عاليه
الى امطار غزيره قد تؤثر على هذه المنطقه
لكن معنا حسين القحطاني متحدث الرسمي باسم
المركز الوطني للارصاد نعم
شكرا لك يا استاذ طارق السلمي مراسل
العربيه من المركز الوطني للارصاد
سجلت الصفقات العقاريه في السعوديه
انخفاضا بنحو 23% خلال العام الماضي وذلك
وفقا ما جاء في تقرير
العقاريه فيما تصدرت منطقه الرياض
والمناطق السعوديه من حيث عدد قيمه
الصفقات المنفذه
خلال العام 2022 شهدت اعداد الصفقات
العقاريه في السعوديه انخفاضا بنحو 30 في
المئه في المقابل شهدت قيمه الصفقات
ارتفاعا بنحو سبعه في المئه حيث بلغت 200
و خمسه مليارات ريال وجاء في التقرير الذي
اصدرته منصه سهيل العقاريه ان غالبيه
الصفقات التي شهدتها السعوديه كانت في
العاصمه الرياض باكثر من 65,000 سنه فقط
وا رغم انها الاعلى في عدد الصفقات الى
انها سجلت ايضا انخفاضا سنويا بسته وعشرين
فاصله او سته وعشرين فاصله خمسه في عدد
الصفقات عدد الصفقات على مستوى السعوديه
سجل العام الماضي رابع انخفاض له على
التوالي حيث تم تسجيل اكثر من
3800.000 صفقه عقاريه في العام 2019 لتبدا
بانخفاض سنوي وصل في العام الماضي يعني
الاف صفقه بانخفاض باكثر من مئه والفين
صفقه خلال الاعوام الاربعه عدد الصفقات
ورغم انخفاضه لان قيمتها ارتفعت خلال
اعوام الخمسه الماضيه ايضا حيث تجاوزت
قيمتها في العام 2018
والمائه 135 مليار ريال لتواصل ارتفاع
التدريجي بعدها وتصل الى مئتين وخمسه
مليارات ريال في العام الماضي وحول نوع
الصفقات العقاريه خلال عام 2022
شكلت صفقات السكنيه منها 85 فيما شكلت
صفقات التجاريه الاخرى خمسه عشر اما من
ناحيه قيمه تلك صفقات فقد سجلت صفقات
السكنيه 60 فاصل خمسه من اجمالي قيمه
الصفقات فيما شكلت قيمه الصفقات التجاريه
مشاهدينا التسعه وثلاثين فاصل خمسه واحاول
النطاقات السعريه للصفقات العقاريه شكلات
الصفقات دون
ريال
82% من اجمالي عدد الصفقات في ما لم
تتجاوز الصفقات بقيمه اكثر من 10 ملايين
ريال اقل منه واحد
قليل الهيئه الملكيه للعلا تكشف عن زياره
اكثر من 185,000 العام الماضي
اهلا بكم من جديد يلتقي اكثر من 200 متدرب
سعودي في كليه التقنيه بمنطقه الجوف في
شمال السعوديه او يتلقون تدريبات موسعه
على الطاقه المتجدده ومجالاتها المتنوعه
تخرجها من التخصص التقاري منذ 2018 حتى
الان اكثر من 300 متدرب وتعمل الكليه على
التصميم والتركيب انظمه الطاقه
المتجدده لتاهيل الخريجين الى سوق العمل
من الكليه التقنيه في الجوف مراسل العربيه
عبد الواحد عبد الحميد هلا عبد الواحد
ياليت تلقي الضوء اكثر على هذه الارقام
التي قراتها قبل قليل وعلى البرنامج
التدريبي على الذي تقدمه الكليه التقنيه
نعم خالد اهلا وسهلا بك كما تعلم نحن هنا
في هذه الكليه التي تقدم التدريب للطلاب
منذ سنوات حيث يتدرب هؤلاء الطلاب على
الطاقه المتجدده من بين تخصصات واقسام
اخرى عده ولكن الحديث عن الطاقه المتجدده
حيث كما تعلم المشروعات الضخمه التي يعني
تحتويها منطقه الجوف تحديدا مشاريع الرياح
همم التربينات الرياح او حتى الالواح
الشمسيه هذه المشروعات الضغط الكثيرين الى
همم الدخول الى الكليه للدراسه والتمتع
بخبره كافيه بهذا التخصص في هذه المجالات
تحديدا خالد نريد ان نتعرف اكثر على كل
هذه التفاصيل ينضم الينا المهندس سليمان
الشمري وهو رئيس قسم التقنيه الكهربائيه
بالكليه اهلا وسهلا بك مهند سليمان نريد
ان نعرف اكثر عن تدريسكم وتدريبكم
للمتدربين خصوصا في هذه المجالات حياك
الله اخوي عبد الواحد حقيقه احنا في اسم
التقل الكهربيه في الكليه التقنيه بالجوك
ندرب على او بتخصص الطاقه المتجدده بالذات
همم ندرب المدربين على همم ما يقارب 2000
ساعه تجريبيه يحصل عليها المدرب بعد تخرج
حقيقه تكون على ما يقارب سنتين دراسيه همم
يحصل فيها المتدرب على ما عده مهارات من
ضمنها تصميم وتركيب الالواح الشمسيه كذلك
همم العمل على صيانه وتركيب بعض المنظمات
الكهربائيه الخاصه كذلك ايضا يكون عندها
مهارات اخرى مثل همم يعني حل المشكله همم
ايضا اعداد التقارير الهندسيه مهند سليمان
يعني احنا نشاهد بعض الطلاب يعملون على
يبدو انه مشروع تخرج مثل هذه السياره التي
يبدو وكان تعمل بالطاقه الشمسيه لو تحدثنا
اكثر عن المشروعات التي يعمل عليها الطلاب
لديكم نعم همم اخي عبد الواحد حقيقه
الطلاب الطلاب البكالوريوس المتواجدين
حاليا يعملوا عملوا على سياره
الطاقه المتجدده التي تنظمها المؤسسه
العامه للتدريب التقني والمهني همم حقيقه
هذه السياره يعني صنعت بالشكل كامل هنا في
الكليه التقنيه بالجوف همم او ما يقابله
80% منها همم تعمل بشكل كامل بالطاقه
المتجدده ايضا همم تعمل في مصادر اخرى
كانت الهدف من هذه السياره انا لا تعمل في
نظام الاشتعال او الاحتراق شكرا جزيلا لك
مهند سليمان على كل هذه التفاصيل التي
زودتنا بها همم بالحديث عن همم الكليه
التقنيه بالجوف
وطبعا تدريب الطاقه المتجدده التي يقدره
الطلاب والمتدربون في هذه الكليه هذه ابرز
التفاصيل خالد من الكليه
التقنيه في الجوف عبد الواحد الحميد مراسل
العربيه
الرياض الان مع محمد الجنه
[موسيقى]
خالد اخبار رياضه حياكم الله يفتتحوا
الاهلي المصري
وهو يستهدف تحقيق ميداليه الجديده في
البطوله التي يشارك فيها للمره الثالثه
على التوالي الثامنه في تاريخه ويستغل
الوصيفه بطل افريقيا البطوله
الاربعاء في الدوري التمهيدي ولا تعد
مواجهه اوكلا سيتي على الفريق اذا كان
بوابته للحصول على الميداليه في 2006 ونجح
الاهلي في تحقيق المركز الثالث في اخر
نسختين من البطوله
اليوم الاخير نافذه انتقالات اللاعبين
الشتويه وفقا نادي تشيلسي على انتقالي
لاعب خط وسط الفريق جورجينيو الى ارسنال
في صفقه قدرت باثني عشر مليون جنيه اه
سيخضع اللاعب الايطالي فحص طبي ويوقع عقدا
لمده عام ونصف وشارك اللاعب في 25 مباراه
هذا الموسم وتمكن من تسجيل ثلاثه اهداف
واعلنها بايرن ميونخ عن ضمن الظهير
البرتغالي ومانشستر سيتي على سبيل الاعاره
مع امكانيه ضمنه بشكل نهائي في الصيف
كانسلوا اختفى بثلاث مشاركات في التشكيله
الاساسيه في 10 مباريات ممكن كاس العالم
وفقد مكانه
بعد خلافه مع المدرب دولا
سجل ميلانا الايطالي
بطل الدوري الموسم الماضي
فشل ميلان في استعاده توازنه في الدوري
الايطالي ووصل لانهيار عقب السقوط بفضيحه
امام فريق ساسول بخمسه اهداف الاثنين بعد
اسبوع من الخساره امام لاتسيو برباعيه
نظيفه ارقام سلبيه لحقته بعد طلقه هزيمه
باربعه اهداف او اكثر ولاول مره في تاريخه
بمبارتين متتاليتين بالدوري الايطالي
ودونت تلقيه لخمسه اهداف على ارضه لاول
مره ايضا منذ عام 1977
ميلان لم يحقق طموحات جماهيره ولم يواكب
ما حققه الموسم الماضي بتتويج بلقب الدوري
الايطالي في رصيده احد عشر انتصارا وخمسه
تعادلات 45 هائم احتل بها المركز الخامس
في جدول الترتيب وبفارق 15 نقطه عن
المتصدر نابولي لتتقلص حظوظه في الحفاظ
على اللقب كما خرج من دوري 16 من بوابه
تورينو وخسر كاس السوبر الايطالي لصالح
غريره انتر ميلان في العاصمه السعوديه
الرياض قبل اسبوعين
لاعبوني لان فشلوا تحت قياده المدرب بيولي
في تحقيق الفوز في اخر خمس مباريات بمختلف
البطولات حيث تلقى الفريق ثلاثه هزائم
وتعادل في مبارتين وينتظره ديربي جديد
امام جاره انتر في الجوله الحاديه
والعشرين الاحد المقبل فيما يبدو ان مصير
بيولي سيكون معلقا بنتائج الفريق في دوري
الابطال وتحديدا عندما يواجه توتنهام
الانجليزيه الشهر المقبل في دور 16 من
المسابقه القريه
[موسيقى]
فاز الهولندي
بالمركز الاول في المرحله الاولى من
طوافيا السعوديه للدراجات الهوائيه في
العلا متسابقوا فريق اوريكا سكوت يتفوق
على الصربي دوسان راجا بيتش من طريقه
البحرين فيكتوريوس ولا الماني ماكسد من
فريق الكوبيديس في المرحله التي انطلقت من
مطار العلا وانتهت في خيبر المسافه نحو
180 كم يعتاليه صداره التصنيف العام قبل
انطلاق المرحله الثانيه
هو اللي يمكننا من صرافه مثل هذه
الفعاليات ويمكننا كذلك من اظهار للعالم
بعض المناطق الجميله من المملكه
وشاهدنا امس الدرعيه وكانت يونسكو سايت
واليوم
العلاقات
مع الفرق العالميه هذه باذن الله همم
بتاهله وتمكنه للمشاركه باذن الله في
طوافات عالميه وايضا همم بطولات ان شاء
الله اسوي ودوريه ان شاء الله يوصف
ان شاء الله نسوي اللي علينا والباقي على
الله
ان شاء الله نقدم افضل اداء يمثل الوطن
[موسيقى]
السياحيه والتسويق في الهيئه الملكيه
لمحافظه العلا فليب جونسون انه يتم انجاز
المشاريع التطويريه بطريقه المستدامه
وحمايه الاسود
التي نقوم بها جمال المنطقه ولا تسلي بها
شيئا من رونقها لذلك يتم ايجاد كل
المشاريع التطويريه بطريقه مستدامه لاننا
نريد صونا وحمايه الوصول المذهله التي
حظيت بها هذه المنطقه على مدى سبعه الاف
عامه لتضلاع على ما هي عليه طيله السبعه
الاف عام المقبله
سوف نحتاج الى فتره اطول نسبيه قبل ان
يبدا الزوار العالم في القدوم الى العلا
والاستمتاع بمناظرها الخلابه لكن خلال
العام 2022 استضفنا
185,000 زائر في العلا وكان 23% منهم
سواحا قدموا من الخارج بالاساس من منطقه
الخليج تلهاء الولايات المتحده ففرنسا
فالمانيا في المملكه المتحده في ايطاليا
فاستراليا في الهند باعتبارها الاسواق
الرئيسيه بالنسبه لنا
احدى العجائب السبعه في العالم العام 2023
وهو انجاز عظيم حقيقته وجده سياحيه لم
تكون معروفه قبل خمسه اعوام لقد احرزنا
تقدما هائلا ولو نظرت الى ما تحويل العلا
ستجد العديد من الفنادق والمناطق واماكن
الانشطه الترفيهيه والتخييم التي لم تكن
موجوده قبل فقط
نتابع معكم والان
هذا هذه التصريحات اللي الرئيس الفلسطيني
محمود عباس بعد لقائه بيوزير خارج
الامريكي
[موسيقى]
الفلسطينيين الانبياء الذين اعتقدوا
ارواحهم في العنف المتقاعد على مدى العام
المصري
يارب
يعانون من الخوف
بسبب خزانه احبهم ومن الخوف على سلامتهم
وامنهم في بيوتهم ومجتمعاتهم واماكن
عبادتهم
نرى انه من الضروري اخذ خطوات سريعه
لتخفيف حده التصعيد والعنف وخلق مساحه
تسمح لنا بسعاده الشعور بالامن
الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين
ناروتو
[موسيقى]
عمري
ان استمر في العمل لتاكد من تمتع
الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين بنفس الحكومه
ولكن مناره
[موسيقى]
كل شيء
موقفكم الثابت والمستمر ضد الارهاب
على
تعزيز العلاقات الشعب الفلسطيني
ومساعدته ايضا على تحسين الحياه والمنسيه
مليون دولار ذهبت الى الاونروا لدعم
الغذاء الغذاء الاحتياجات الغذائيه
واللقاحات همم
وايضا اللاجئين وفي دعم مجالي التعليم
الرجاء
عندما زار الرئيس
المنطقه في يوليو الماضي تعاهد ايضا
بالتبرع بمبلغ 100 مليون دولار لشبكه
المستشفيات في القدس الشرقيه
[موسيقى]
الرابع من شبكه الاتصالات فورت نايت ونعمل
على تنفيذ ذلك
الرئيس ايضا قام بتعيين هذه العمل والذي
هو موجود معنا اليوم كاول ممثل للشؤون
الفلسطينيه
في القدس الشرقيه
لوزير الخارجيه الامريكي مع رئيس
الفلسطيني محمود عباس
[موسيقى]